alright guys dealing with a cheater is
one of the most demotivating frustrating
and rage-inducing things that can happen
to you in a competitive game hackers
just suck and lord knows a lot of the
anti cheat systems and reporting tools
out there leave a lot to be desired when
it comes to effectiveness but what if I
told you there was one guy one guy who
was willing to go so far as to hold a
developer hostage willing to go so far
as to receive death threats in order to
fight back against hackers ruining
soloqueue everywhere that's what today's
don't at me is all about
[Music]
all right so you may have noticed things
look a little different around here
right now and that's because like
everybody else that the score a sports
I'm working from home to help stop the
spread of kovat 19 but rest assured the
content will not be stopping not even a
little all right so let's get back to
the video here
hackers cheaters Waller's aimbot errs
whatever you call them we've all
encountered them and they suck they ruin
your game and waste your time and even
happens to the pros so what do you do
right click on their name you click
report and most of the time nothing
happens you move on with your life but
there's one guy out there who's spending
his life maybe even risking his life to
expose cheaters and hackers and get them
banned he's kind of like the cops for
gamers at least when it comes to
overwatch cops central organization of
police specialists fighting crime in a
future his name is muhammad al Sharif II
but me usually goes by gamer doc and he
runs the overwatch police department
there a community of people dedicated to
catching and exposing not only people
who use cheap software but the people
who develop it and sell it to see I bet
you think your game is full of cheaters
lord knows I've complained about csgo
matchmaking enough times but it's
nothing compared to the hacking problem
that overwatch seems to have it looks
like an AI almost but I think it's a
human I don't know what to be honest at
this point so just like completely hard
walking this game is infested with
cheaters and Blizzard by all accounts is
doing a pretty bad job of controlling it
so with a weak anti cheat and know like
ESEA or FPL equivalent for overwatch
anybody who wants to play is stuck in
this hell of macro scripts aimbots and
wall hacks and that's where gamer doc
and the OWP d come in they're like
sheriffs in a Wild West Town full
hackers so if you spot a hacker for
example and you're tired of reporting
them and not seeing them banned by
Blizzard you use the OWP DS pull
to report them which is kind of like a
police report we have like a really cool
report system so everything's like
organized and good so we'll take the
date date of the incident the time of
the incident and the battle tank of the
person that was cheating and the battle
tank of the person that was in the game
and then we collect all that information
and then hand it over to Blizzard for
them to investigate the incident we also
like sent a video footage of the like
one or two minute clips of the person
cheating and also like a full replay
with any luck the suspect gets banned
after that but OWP D and GAE Murdock
also publicly named and shamed cheaters
and sometimes that gets the job done
surprisingly two or three or four
cheaters came forward to me in my DM
saying that they actually feel
embarrassed that they're cheating they
just like come to me like some kind of
like a reflection that they're saying
I'm sixteen years old I just wanted to
feel cool and this kind of stuff I'm
like you can just do the same thing by
just practicing so I do either get like
these weird messages people like
self-reflecting or something like that
like really sorry they are cheating they
also keep extensive files on active
cheaters so you can see what kind of
cheats they're probably using and when
they're online but the chief of the
overwatch PD doesn't just email Blizzard
and call it a day sometimes he takes the
law into his own hands like the time he
got his hands on the full source code
for a cheat and threatened to release it
to the public
if Blizzard didn't take action like we
had a source code an entire source code
of a cheat that we sent to Blizzard
a couple of times like for the past six
months and Bridget didn't detect it at
all I got to my limits and basically put
out a tweet saying in a week time if
Blizzard doesn't get this cheat detected
I will release the entire public cheats
for everyone to use in a week time in
five days actually the cheat got finally
detected and it was the biggest
detection ever it was like around 5,000
years banned now not everybody thought
issuing Blizzard a one-week ultimatum
was the best idea but desperate times
breed desperate men he Murdock spends
his own time and money to infiltrate dis
cords and private forums that cheaters
use to gather evidence on hackers he's
even become the moderator of a few of
these cheating servers himself to catch
people in the act and the hackers have
no idea he's basically an undercover
agent at this point now I said earlier
that gay Murdoch might be risking his
life to do this and I know it sounds
crazy but this dude gets death threats
there's a lot of people were just like 7
death threats towards me we're just like
shame my shame how I look or just saying
how they're gonna get a hit man after me
and trying to get me killed or people
who are also like faking my I dress like
they have talk'st my address but none of
it really happened I know it's never
going to happen because I'm not really
scared of these kind of guys I'm not
really scared of any developer out there
because at the end of the day I am the
one who's chasing them and they are the
ones who are hiding now when it comes to
the actual work this guy does we're not
just talking about new masters 69
installing an aimbot he found on google
gamer dock also goes after the people
who sell develop and distribute these
cheats sometimes he says he has one
cheat developer coming to him with
information about another so OWP Dee can
take them down and eliminate the
business competition it's crazy by the
way guys business is good the more
sophisticated hacks can cost you over
$1000 to buy into and hundreds of
dollars a month to subscribe to all to
be good at a dead game I am kidding
overwatch people please do not come to
my house and kill me now death threats
aside it's also a big job to help lead
this community of hacker hunters and all
the infrastructure that supports it and
gamer doc has a full time job in real
life on a week-to-week basis he says
that o WPD takes away as much time as a
part-time job would it's not like
blizzard's helping either send them a
ton of information every single week or
like even every like four days I send
them like a ton of information on every
single cheats that's available currently
files
what to do everything pretty much and we
just don't see anything happening
recently they even said that they had
two big anti-cheat efforts which really
didn't do anything then stop a bit of a
cheat developers for like three days
five days and then they cut their cheats
back running up okay okay so let's recap
here countless hours of work death
threats no help from Blizzard kind of
makes you wonder why this guy would even
do this well I asked him exactly that I
do this because I love eSports and I
love video games in general and because
I'm now 24 years old you know I've had
my fair share of eSports already and so
I wanted to do something good for the
community I know what it's like to go
against the cheater and I know what it's
like to lose against someone that you
shouldn't lose so I just I usually just
do this because of the more next
generation of gamers so this is sort of
a set but it's it's also hella real this
bookshelf was always there this
bookshelf was on the opposite end of the
room so I moved them together so you
guys could see all my nerdy treasures
you know maybe you guys can do a little
scavenger hunt what's in the back of my
my set here don't ever talk to me don't
ever [ __ ] talk to me about cyberpunk
if you have to if you haven't read the
seminal piece of trash that is Batman
digital justice just don't even talk to
me